hey legal eagles ah the age-old question
of how to choose the right law school
currently there are over 250 different
law schools in the US alone and choosing
between them can be daunting but today
we're going to go over the main concerns
that you should consider when deciding
between law schools so stick around
[Music]
there are a number of factors to
consider when choosing between law
schools and no one-size-fits-all but the
first consideration is what job do you
want when you graduate from law school
certain jobs require a pedigree and
others not so much
there's no way around it but sometimes
law school rank matters lots of people
pay attention to it if you want to be a
Supreme Court clerk and then parlay that
clerkship into a big firm litigation job
well that requires the highest law
school pedigree that's out there you
need to go to a top law school other
jobs on the other hand like working for
a small or medium-sized law firm often
don't require as much pedigree or top
law school rank some jobs don't require
really any pedigree at all and in fact
sometimes you can get into a district
attorney job or a public defender's job
without the same kind of pedigree of a
top law school that would be necessary
to become big firm litigator or a
supreme court clerk so before you think
about how you want to get there think
about where you want to go it's
important to know the destination before
you choose the right path if your ideal
job requires a top law school well then
you'll want to aim for a top law school
the next factor I would take into
consideration is the geographical
location of where you want to practice
certainly it's no surprise that top law
schools probably open up the most
options but often if you want to work in
a specific geographical region there are
certain regional law schools that are
considered just as good as many of the
better ranked law schools for the
purposes of that particular geographical
location certain regional law schools
punch way above their weight for the
region that they're located in if you
know you want to end up in a particular
location you might go to a law school in
that area the alumni network might be
well-connected in that area you might be
able to get
more networking opportunities in that
city or that state so in certain
circumstances a regional law school can
have advantages over a higher ranked Law
School so for example if you knew you
wanted to practice in Los Angeles
California you might consider going to
Loyola or Pepperdine in the LA area and
while they're not the top-ranked law
schools in the country they punch above
their weight in the Los Angeles area by
the same token however going to a much
higher ranked law school might open up
even more opportunities in a wider
geographical location and frankly if you
go to some of the top law schools then
it shouldn't be too difficult to get a
job in any particular location but
that's always something to consider
especially if different law schools
offer different financial packages and
financial aid as well sometimes going to
a regional school can save you a lot of
money but you have to weigh the pros and
cons versus going to a better ranked
school that might open up more doors
outside of just a particular
geographical location and sometimes
people decide that they don't want to
stay in a particular city or state and
they want to move to somewhere else
going to a higher ranked school can
sometimes open it up those kind of
opportunities which brings me to the
next factor that you should probably
consider when deciding between law
schools and that's how much are you
willing to pay unfortunately there's not
much difference in terms of the public
or RAK rates that you see from different
law schools and the amount that you pay
doesn't really correlate to the rank of
that school in fact it's often inversely
correlated where the better schools
actually charge less than some of the
lower ranked schools and some of the
for-profit schools charge the most out
of everybody but there's really not a
huge amount of variation between the
published rates of the highest ranked
schools and the lowest ranked schools
but that doesn't mean there's no
difference at all
generally speaking public law schools
are going to charge less often tens of
thousands of dollars less per year than
their private counterparts but the
biggest difference comes in the form of
financial aid
just because the published tuition is
high doesn't mean that students are
actually going to pay that much there is
often a huge amount of competition
amongst law schools to attract the best
and brightest law students
so different law schools offer a huge
variation in financial aid which can
sometimes result in scholarships from a
few hundred dollars to several thousand
dollars or even full rides and full-ride
pluses it can result in a huge
difference in the amount that you pay at
the end of the day when you go to law
school so often you have to make a
decision between going to a higher
ranked law school or going to one that's
going to pay you more money to go there
and when you're talking about law school
where tuition alone can cost fifty
thousand dollars a year not to mention
living expenses it's not surprising that
law students often graduate with over
two hundred thousand dollars in law
school debt alone so getting a large
financial aid package can have a huge
effect on your quality of life when you
graduate from law school another factor
to consider is do you want to go into a
specialty in the law what most people
don't know is that law schools teach
basically the same thing especially in
your first year and usually into your
second year and unfortunately no law
school really prepares you for
practicing as an attorney no one feels
ready to practice when they graduate
from law school and that's true whether
you go to the number one law school in
the country or the number one hundredth
law school in the country it's shocking
but they all teach basically the same
thing but a handful of schools really
excel in a few specialty areas like tax
or entertainment law or law and
economics so if you know that you want
to go into one of these specialty fields
that generally the kind of fields that
require an LLM or a masters of the law
then you might consider going to one of
those schools that really excels in that
area but outside of those really
specialty areas I would not assume that
any law school is going to teach you
anything different from another law
school and unless you're going into one
of those LLM type areas odds are you're
gonna get the exact same education as
anywhere else there aren't that many
areas in which this specialty applies
tax is the one that really comes out so
if you know that you want to go into one
of these specialty fields that require
is an advanced law degree then you might
consider going to a law school that has
a very high ranked specialty program in
that area
the next big consideration when thinking
about law schools is whether you want to
go into big
most students think that they want to go
into big law when they start law school
whether it's actually the best thing for
them or not and while it's certainly not
the route for everyone it is the route
that I took I've been a big firm lawyer
for over ten years I've recruited I have
mentored summer associates and here's
what I think are the most important
takeaways if you want to go into big law
when you're deciding between law schools
if you want to go the big firm route you
generally need to go to one of the best
schools in the country the most
prestigious schools at the top of the
250 law schools in the country there are
three at the very top that are always
changing in position for number one and
that's usually Yale Harvard in Stanford
which one of those three schools is
ranked number one in a particular year
largely depends on who you ask but
generally those three schools are
considered the top three schools in the
country if you're able to get into the
roughly top half of your class at one of
the top law schools in the country you
stand a very good chance of being
competitive with the top firms in the
country and getting a big firm job now
apart from the top three law schools
there are what people generally refer to
as the top tier of law schools we often
call the tier one law schools or t14 law
schools those are also almost
universally considered the top law
schools in the country roughly the top
10% you'll hear people talk about the
top 14 law schools in the country
sometimes as its top 15 and sometimes
it's the top 20 really there's not a
whole lot of difference between those
top tier schools those top 10% of law
schools or schools like NYU Berkeley
UCLA Georgetown Michigan Duke Columbia
I'm also leaving out a whole bunch of
those top tier schools but they're
generally considered the top schools in
the country even though you're in one of
the top law schools in the country you
still need to do reasonably well in your
class in order to get a big firm job but
if you're safely in the top third of
your class at a tier one school you
stand a very good chance of getting a
big firm job or a clerkship after that I
would say that there is sort of a second
tier of law schools the law schools
ranked generally between 20 and 100 if
you go to one of these schools
and you want to go the big firm route
generally you have to be in the top five
to ten percent of your class you have to
do very well at these tier two schools
in order to get the most competitive
jobs because you're competing with
thousands of people that went to the top
tier schools and you have to demonstrate
that you are above the rest of your
class so it can be very difficult if you
want to go to a law school that is
outside the top 100 and you still want
to go the the prestigious big firm route
well it's still possible but you're
really going to have to differentiate
yourself from the rest of your class you
really have to excel and be roughly the
top one or two people maybe the top five
in your class in order to get the kind
of ranking that would allow you to get
the big firm jobs these are the kind of
rankings and grades that are also going
to let you transfer to a different
school if you want to go that route but
keep in mind that big law is not all
there is there's all kinds of jobs in
law and you shouldn't assume that big
law is necessarily the right one for you
you've got to work thousands of hours
and it can really burn you out so don't
just assume that big law is the one and
only route in law school there's lots of
different careers in legal field and you
may not want to go into big law in
particular additionally when you're
thinking about different careers in law
check out the data that the ABA puts out
on different law schools the ABA
publishes information on each school it
will tell you how successful their
graduates are what states that those
graduates practice in and it will also
tell you the average income that
graduates from that particular law
school make so don't just rely on
generalities but really dig in and see
if graduates from the law school that
you're considering are going into the
kind of jobs that you really want to go
into so that being said well everyone's
situation is different and there's never
a general best law school for everyone I
do want to give you some general tips
all things being equal I would say go to
a higher ranked law school the higher
ranked law schools especially when you
get into the top tier of law schools
really open up many different options
for you and maybe a year from now when
you're a 2l or three years from now what
you want out of your legal career might
be completely different than one
you want when you start out so going to
a higher ranked law firm often if
there's a big difference in the ranking
can really open up some different
options if not now then perhaps later
down the line so all things being equal
you might consider a higher ranked law
school also again all things being equal
you might consider going to a school
that offers more financial aid if you're
deciding between schools within the top
tier or within the top three and the top
tier and one school gives you a full
ride and another school gives you zero
financial aid I would probably choose
the one that gives you more financial
aid despite the fact that there might be
a 10 rank difference between school
number one in school number ten there's
probably not going to be that much of a
difference in terms of your employment
prospects and certainly very little in
terms of what's actually taught at the
law school so you could do yourself a
huge favor by taking money for the
slightly lower ranked school if that
comes with more financial aid and you'd
probably be very happy to graduate
debt-free from a top-tier law school if
the alternative was to go to another
top-ranked Floss school with a ton of
debt often that can be the difference
between zero debt and $250,000 worth of
debt and when you graduate you know if
you don't go into big law and you go
into a legal career that pays you know
seventy or eighty thousand dollars which
is the median salary for an attorney
having or not having two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars worth of loans to
repay over a ten year time period can
make all the difference in your quality
of life again all things being equal go
to a law school that is closer to the
geographical location that you know you
want to practice if you know that you
want to practice in Boston then by all
means go to a law school in Boston it's
very helpful to be able to interview
with a lot of firms in the area in which
you're going to law school otherwise the
alternative might be having to fly
across the country in order to do the
same number of interviews or or to
interview with the same type of firm
with law schools don't tell you is that
at the beginning of your second year
you're going to be doing a ton of
interviews with firms and
governmental agencies to try and line up
the job that you have when you graduate
from law school and it is so much easier
to be able to take on-campus interviews
with the type of firms that you want to
practice in the future because local
firms are more likely to hold on campus
interviews at a local law school it's
just the economics of the situation so
going to a law school in the city or the
state where you want to practice can
make all the difference in your second
year when you're taking interviews for
the firms that you want to work for in
the future so this is just the tip of
the iceberg in terms of what you should
do before law school if you want more
strategies and tactics for what to do
before starting law school download our
free ultimate pre-law checklist it's our
gift to you the link to that is down
below and it will give you a head start
when you get to law school also please
click the like and subscribe buttons the
more people that subscribe to this
channel the more videos we can make on
how to crush law school so did I miss
any considerations that you have about
choosing your law school are you
choosing between law school right now
have you already decided let me know in
the comments below I would love to hear
from you and until next time at legal
eagle think like a lawyer and ace your
exams ah the age-old question of how to
choose the right law school but today
we're gonna go over the main concerns
that you should consider when deciding
between one so before you think about
what you want so before you think about
so before you think about